hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
section seven of david hume's inquiry
concerning human understanding
is concerned with this this question
where do we
actually get the concept of power
or cause or necessary connection
from and he tells us that there are no
ideas which occur in metaphysics more
obscure
and uncertain than those of power force
energy or necessary connection and
at the same time it is at every moment
necessary for us to treat in all of our
disquisitions
so he's saying we can't just substitute
terms for each other which is one of the
problems in philosophy quite often
not just in philosophy everybody does
this in all sorts of other fields
as well but if we want to get to the
bottom of things we need to figure out
where does this idea actually come from
and
hume wants to treat this as a good
empiricist so somebody who's in the
tradition
that goes back you could say officially
to john locke he actually mentions locke
here
in the treaties in the previous section
and continues on to the the present with
with david hume
you could trace it back a little bit
further if you want but we don't have to
worry about that at this point and so he
says well
let's think about this is it a complex
idea
if it is well then we can figure it out
by definition
you know we define uh the the idea
essentially we
analyze it into its component terms and
hopefully ultimately get down to simple
ideas
and then we know those simple ideas so
we're good right and he says
well the problem is simple
ideas are going to require
looking at what he calls impressions
or original sentiments he says when
we've pushed up definition so the most
simple ideas and find still some
ambiguity and obscurity
what resources are we then possessed of
by what invention can we throw light
upon these ideas
and render them all together precise and
determine determinate to our
intellectual view
and here's where we get to empiricism
right which says
look at our experience produce
the impressions or original sentiments
from which the ideas are
copied remember too that for hume ideas
of the mind are
copies of sentiments or
impressions or passions that that we've
had
so they're sort of like you know less
vivid that's really the only distinction
that we can we can maintain between them
so we've got to figure out okay
where did we actually get this idea from
and then we can think about okay we we
had that original core idea
and then we kind of transformed it and
we turned it into a more complex idea
that then we apply
we transfer to all sorts of other things
so
hume actually brings up three possible
places where we could find this
impression of power could be
observing material external objects
and their relations to each other it
could be observing
our relation to those exterior objects
into our own body
through how it is that volition or the
will
moves our body around like i'm waving my
hands right now right i'm choosing to do
that right
i have power or it could be something
that's
you could say even more internal
observing
how we can will our own ideas
and consideration of those ideas humans
going to reject
each one of these in turn not saying of
course that we don't actually observe
things happening in the world that we
don't observe
us raising our hands that we don't
observe our own
willing producing ideas that does happen
but that can't be the source of our
impression
of power right so
he says when we look about us towards
external objects and consider the
operation of causes
we're never able in a single instance
and we're looking at individual
instances to discover any power
necessary connection any quality which
binds the effect to the cause
and renders the one an infallible
consequence of the other we only find
all we actually do observe
is that one does in fact follow the
other it gives the example of billiard
balls
the impulse of one billiard ball is
attended with motion in the second
this is the hole that appears to the
outward senses the mind
has no sentiment or inward impression
from this because it's not there in the
stuff
right it's only observing what's
happening
and so he says in reality there's no
part of matter that does
ever by its sensible qualities discover
any power or energy or give us any
ground to imagine it can produce
anything or be followed by any other
object
solidity extension motion these
qualities are all completed themselves
never point out any other event which
may result from them
so you know external objects are not
going to give us
this idea of necessary connection
there's no case that we can look at and
say ah
i found the cause right there in the
middle in between the
uh or i found the causality rather in
between the cause
and the effect it just doesn't happen
so hume says well you know
we are causes our minds make our body
do something uh specifically the part of
our mind that we call
the will or volition he says that
an act of volition produces motion in
our limbs we
know this by consciousness so we acquire
the idea of power energy
from that right and he says well let's
let's think about this
there's three big problems that are
coming up with this he says
first is there any principle in all
nature more mysterious than the union of
soul with the body
which by which a supposed spiritual
substance
acquires an influence over a material
one that the most refined thought is
able to actuate the grossest matter
he says no we we this is totally obscure
we don't understand this at all and we
still don't understand it actually in
our own time
you know we can say well we understand
how the brain and the body interact
but you know if we're more than our just
our brains
because there is this problem of well
how do we get consciousness out of
brains
uh we've still got this problem of
explaining how i raise my hand right now
how i
will to raise my hand and so he says
if by consciousness we perceived any
power energy in the will
we must know this power we must know its
connection with the effect
we must know the secret union of soul
and body we don't
so he says second we're not able to move
all the organs of the body with a like
authority and we can't assign any reason
besides experience for so remarkable a
difference between one or another he's
got some great examples here
why has the will and influence over the
tongue
and the fingers but not over the heart
or the liver and you might say well yeah
but what about yogis and biofeedback
okay sure yeah you can do like
breathing exercises and you can do
relaxation and stuff like that
but you still don't have the same degree
of control over your liver
as you do your fingers or your your eyes
or
any of those sorts of things and even in
the things that you do control
you're not controlling all of it right
with your will
you want your finger to do something
there's there's all everything about
smiling for example
you know you choose to smile and all
these different muscles do all their
things
you're not conscious of all those causes
happening you're just conscious that
you're
making a a smile or not making a smile
some people's smiles are actually
grimaces
then he brings up a third thing
he says that we learn from anatomy that
the
immediate object of power and voluntary
motion is not the member itself which is
moved
but certain muscles and nerves and and
he says animal
spirits now we've rejected that notion
this time and perhaps something still
more minute and more unknown so we don't
really
understand that uh he says we can
conclude
that our idea of power is not copied
from any sentiment or consciousness of
power within ourselves
when we give rise to animal motion or
apply our limbs to their proper use and
office
that their emotion follows from a
command of the will is a matter of
common experience
but the power or energy by which this is
affected
is unknown and inconceivable so that's
not getting us yet to the
the single instance where wow i see the
causality at work we just know that it
works but we don't we don't actually
observe it
what about turning inward and just
thinking about our mind itself
that seems to have way better prospects
you're not mixing it up with
you know bodily things or external the
world or anything like that
just thinking about your own thoughts
you can will yourself
to consider an idea right think about a
pink elephant right now
or don't think about a pink elephant and
you'll think about a pink elephant
because i told you not to
you've got an idea in your head take a
dumbo
you know the disney elephant with the
big ears and just make them pink
or take an elephant that you've seen
somewhere else and make that pink you
don't even have to have actually seen an
elephant in real life
you just have seen it in a magazine or a
website or whatever
you've got some idea that you can you
can work with well isn't that
a great example of where we get our idea
of power from
and he says well we've got some problems
here too it says first it must be
allowed when we know a power we know the
very circumstance
in the cause by which it is enabled to
produce the effect
for these are supposed to be synonymous
we must therefore
know both the cause and effect and the
relation
between them but do we pretend to be
acquainted with the nature of the human
soul and the nature of an idea
or the aptitude of the one to produce
another this is a real creation of
production
something out of nothing and he says we
don't understand this at all
we don't know how our minds actually
work you might say well
human haven't you been examining this
the whole time he says well we've been
delving into it a bit but we don't we
haven't gotten to the bottom of it
second he points out another thing
that's very important the command of the
mind over itself is limited as well as
its command over the body
and these limits are not known by reason
or any acquaintance with the nature of
cause and effect
only by experience and observation as in
all other natural events and in the
operation of external
objects so that's not going to teach us
and then he says third
this self-command is very different at
different times a man in health
possesses more of it than one
languishing with sickness
we're more master of our thoughts in the
morning than in the evening apparently
he was a morning
guy fasting then after a full meal can
we give any reason except
experience for these variations where
then
is the power of which we pretend to be
conscious
and he says that you know i mean think
about volition itself
reflect upon it do you find anything in
it like this creative power by which it
raises from nothing a new idea
and with a kind of fiat imitates the the
omnipotence of its maker
who called forth into existence all the
various scenes of nature and he says
so far from being conscious of this
energy and the will
it requires as certain experience as
that of which we're possessed to
convince us
that such extraordinary effects ever do
result from a simple act
of volition so there's no single
instance that we can find where we've
got this
simple idea you know that we're is being
derived from our impressions or
sentiments we're just not finding it
so okay well if that's the case he says
maybe we really don't understand this
stuff
he says
as we can have no idea of anything which
never appeared to our outward sense or
inward sentiment
the necessary conclusion seems to be
that we have no idea
of connection or power at all and that
these words are absolutely without
any meaning when employed either in
philosophical reasonings or
common life so we're really just talking
nonsense
when we talk about power or causality
if we can't trace it back to some
original idea
or impression rather or sentiment
that would be a real problem wouldn't it
that's that's the way some people do
interpret him
but they're wrong because he goes on
shortly after that and he says well
you know we actually do have
a source for this he says it appears
that this idea of a necessary connection
among events
arises not from one single thing
but from a number of similar instances
which occur
of the constant conjunction of these
events and he says
there's nothing in a number of instances
different from every single instance
which is supposed to be exactly similar
except
only that after a repetition of similar
instances the mind is carried by habit
upon the appearance of one event to
expect its usual attendant
and to believe it will exist so he says
this connection which we feel in the
mind this customary transition
of the imagination from one object to
its usual attendant is
the sentiment or impression from which
we form the idea of power or necessary
connection
this connection we feel in the mind
which is based ultimately
on habit or as he's called it in an
earlier
section custom it is the habit or custom
that gives us this idea of power it's
not
any one single instance it's the
repetition
that provides us with this idea which is
so
indispensable to both our philosophical
reasonings and to our everyday life
you